hey everyone how's it going my name is
myugo and welcome back to my channel one
of the most difficult things for me for
when i was starting out my career was
building my professional network i had a
few friends and acquaintances from
college and colleagues that i worked
with during my internships but it felt
like my circle wasn't really growing as
fast as it should and i felt stuck and
for the longest time i didn't know what
i could possibly do
even though it was staring at me right
in the face email and not just any email
but an email to someone you've never
spoken to before aka a cold email oh and
cold dms also work in this case too for
non-email platforms i think like not
enough people realize that this is
something that can be done in like
modern everyday society because i
definitely didn't know but i realized
that if you do it right then it can be
the thing that catapults you into the
next stage of your career i used to be
so afraid of writing cold emails it's
one of those things in our day-to-day
lives that feels like as scary and as
nerve-wracking as walking into a party
without knowing anybody you have no idea
how it's gonna go like is it gonna be a
great success or is it gonna be a
complete disaster and that's part of the
appeal of it honestly because i used to
worry so much like what would they think
would i come across as a weirdo or like
totally pathetic would i make a bad
first impression and like completely
ruin the chances of a good career right
out of the gate in short
no realistically speaking anyone who's
in a position to get a cold email from
someone like you probably gets a lot of
them in their day to day they've seen
the good the bad the cringy and they
know what to expect so your email will
probably be nowhere near like the worst
that they've seen in fact i can assure
you it'll probably be fine you know in
case you're sending out a cold email to
someone who might not be like as
established or something like that then
a cold email can actually be a really
good boost to their confidence if you
kind of compliment them on their work so
yeah anytime that there's like worry or
anxiety or fear about anything then you
know through lots of therapy i learned
one technique is to really think what's
the worst that could happen in this case
it's that they say no which is like a
totally acceptable thing for them to do
they could also ignore your email or
just like never get around to looking at
it which we all know it's like that's
totally normal it happens and it's not
that big of a deal in fact in the years
that i bring cold emails i always try to
remind myself that if someone doesn't
respond
it doesn't mean that they're like
actively judging me or like choosing to
ignore me a lot of the time i try to
remind myself that they don't think i'm
like a weirdo or that like i've
embarrassed myself or like any of those
things because likely they barely know
anything about me honestly it's just
that people are busy and they probably
don't have the bandwidth to help like
it's largely not too personal so after
thinking about the worst case scenario
think about the best thing that can
happen when you write a cold email when
you connect with someone you add them to
your network and so you can provide each
other things like opportunities
feedback advice and even friendship and
support and that actually happens
because sending cold emails of all
things has been one of the things that
really helped me to connect with people
that i never would have connected with
otherwise so yes if you can do it right
it's almost kind of like a cheat code in
life you might think that you have to
have like 10 mutual friends on social
media or something before you can like
reach out to connect but i honestly
think that can be kind of limiting like
it keeps your circle contained when in
fact it could actually be limitless like
this is one of the most beautiful things
about the internet honestly but sending
cold emails isn't exactly typing up hi
please be my friend and just like
sending it directly to beyonce's email
it's actually a skill that you need to
work to develop that you can hone and
improve on over time and if you know how
to do it well then you'll improve your
chances of getting a response which
means that you can more likely find like
your next bff or your co-founder or
whatever because really think about it
at the end of the day we're always
connecting with people in our lives and
especially so in our professional lives
and so this whole thing of like
connecting and reaching out to people is
just a muscle that you're going to want
to build up so you can use a cold email
for a bunch of different things like
maybe you're looking for a job and so
you want to connect with like recruiters
or hiring managers to sow seeds for a
job opportunity in the future or you can
expand your network of colleagues by
networking with other people in your
trades software engineers whatever at
your level you can ask for advice and
give them feedback if they want it and
you know best case scenario you get to
like work on a project together which is
pretty cool side note sometimes i wonder
if like musical collaborations also
start with like a cold dm but you know
what the core motivation behind cold
emailing cold dming is most often the
same basically you do it when you want
something from someone and that's not
always a bad or selfish thing sometimes
you might want like a job or advice yes
but other times you just like want to
connect with other people sometimes you
might just want a minute of somebody's
time like all of that is really
understandable and acceptable but
because of this kind of like universally
understood motivation behind cold emails
it can be kind of tricky to craft one it
can be a hard tone to strike like not to
be too desperate not to be too cocky not
to ask for something undeserved and also
not to beat around the bush those are
actually the kinds of things that i see
in the emails that i get because
recently i've started to get more and
more cold emails from people which is
like a super cool thing don't get me
wrong but it's really opened my eyes to
see which kinds of emails catch my eye
and which ones don't so here are my best
tips for writing a cold email to someone
you want to connect with
[Music]
this might sound childishly simple but
you'd be surprised in the kinds of
things that i see in the emails that i
get so hello blah it's nice to meet you
is totally fine you don't need to
overthink it so long as you include it
oh and please make sure that their name
is spelled correctly here because as
someone with like a non-english name as
soon as i see someone misspell my name
it's like not a great first impression
let me just say
if the person doesn't know who you are
and you've never met them then it's
really important to provide some context
so include one to three clear simple
sentences about who you are give them
helpful background info that's
interesting to help them paint a picture
about who you are like are you a student
or maybe you're a full-time engineer
where in the world do you live what's
the focus of your work the biggest
issues i've seen with cold emails
revolves around information it's either
that there's no information like no
background context about who you are or
they provide way too much which can also
come off kind of weird and creepy you
are a stranger to them after all so uh
it's helpful to remember that my piece
of advice here which is maybe not the
best advice but i don't know how to say
it is just to be like a normal friendly
good kind person another piece of
context that's often omitted in emails
is the why like whenever i receive a
cold email myself a question pops into
my head like why did they email me
specifically what do you what do you
want from me like am i just like another
name and a long list of people on
linkedin if it's obvious that i'm bcc
number 50 then i'm way less likely to
respond to it so i always really
appreciate it when people are just
straight up about it like why are you
writing this email today i think it's
kind of a kind thing to tell them why
you're reaching out because then they
don't have to do the math of just like
why are you talking to me right now just
be upfront and honest about it like just
give them a sense of context about
what's happening here's a couple of
examples
i'm writing to you today is i'm trying
to expand my network of software
engineers doing machine learning as it's
a field i'm trying to get into
i've been trying to switch into this
field since i realized that front end
development is not for me and i'm
looking for some guidance on the machine
learning field
i'm writing to you today about the job
posting on your careers page for the
data analyst role i'm currently in the
market for a data analyst scientist
position after finishing my master's in
data science at ucsd i'm writing to you
today as we have a lot of similar
interesting commonalities and i'd love
to connect with you i would not try to
be like overly eager or spammy about it
but i would include like a url to your
linkedin or your portfolio or personal
website people are used to those and
they appreciate the opportunity to go
deeper and find out more about you and
your work it does also make you feel
more like legitimate and intentional
about you reaching out
so when you're writing a cold email or
dm then make sure you do your homework
and you know what they're about if it's
appropriate then you can add like a
personal touch and tell them that you're
a fan of their work if you are because
one of the worst things is when a cold
email is generic and you can tell that
it's like a template and they switched
out just names and like pronouns and
stuff like that like it's okay to have a
template but like definitely make sure
that their name is in there and maybe
like a sentence or two that's more
personal about who they are because when
it's literally just like a copy-pasted
email where they change nothing it's
super duper obvious
[Music]
okay now i know this might sound kind of
weird in this context but really what do
you need from this person and what do
you need them to do because in most
cases there is something that you
actually want for the other person to do
so just be clear about it you don't
really know what their communication
style is so like if you're all subtle
and shy about it then they're probably
not gonna spend a lot of time trying to
decode what you mean and they're just
gonna move on unless they're super nice
and if they're super nice then great yes
those people do actually exist but you
can't rely on everybody to be super nice
and not busy in responding to emails
from people that they've never met if
you're upfront about what you're about
they will take you seriously
[Music]
and lastly when in doubt just make
everything super duper easy for them
like if you want to call with them then
give them your availability right away
if you want them to look over something
then attach that file or link it or
whatever not to sound like a jerk but if
that next step isn't like easy for me to
do and it takes like five back and forth
to get there then i might lose interest
and stop replying like if their request
is like too vague or like i don't really
know what they want or it's just like
really unclear what exactly i'm supposed
to do then it just becomes work for what
will always be a favor from me keep it
simple and just ask for it so here's
some examples i was wondering if you'd
be open to a 30 minute call this week or
next i have a few questions about this
role here's a link to my calendars to
schedule something
i would love your feedback on my resume
and cover letter attached specifically
i'm trying to get a better sense of how
it can be better in listing my past
experiences and skills to get a data
science role would you be interested in
a 30-minute call to get to know each
other here's my calendar to schedule
and quick side note maybe my most like
favorite tip of all use calendly i'm not
sponsored by them or anything but i just
genuinely love it it's an app that
allows you to integrate your calendar
and set your availability so that people
can schedule time with you so no instead
of that like annoying back and forth of
like what's your availability look like
well i'm free on this day and this day
from this time this time okay but what
about three o'clock okay no but what
about five o'clock okay yeah that sounds
great it's just so much easier with
calendly it's literally just like a
one-click solution it's just like these
are the times that i'm free pick one and
then it gets scheduled on your calendar
just like that it's so nice i highly
recommend it i'll leave a link in the
description box down
below so if you find someone's email
address or you want to dm them on
instagram or linkedin or whatever then
try writing one if you're serious and
well intentioned about it and especially
so if you can offer something to them
then you'd be surprised at what can come
from it thank you all so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed it i've been
making a lot of like career related
videos recently so if you haven't
subscribed yet then make sure to do so
thank you so much to my members for
supporting my channel and my content i
left a little bonus content for you
linked in the description box down below
that you too can access if you're not a
member by clicking join down below all
right everybody good luck out there
write all those cold emails take these
tips and expand your network and i'll
see you next time bye